seit tagen über feld wladimir putin die
ukraine und wir bei bild wir wollen hier
aus unserem virtuellen studio genau
erklären was da vor sich geht mit all
unseren animationen und grafiken denn in
der ukraine
da tobt ein krieg von david auf der
einen seite und goliath auf der anderen
die russen die nutzen nämlich in der
ukraine ihren legendären
t-72 kampf man sah sie sehen dieses
ungeheuer aus stachen neben mir 40
tonnen schwer seit jahrzehnten im
einsatz
kampferprobt das muss man so sagen mit
einer mehrere zentimeter dicken
panzerung was uns aufgefallen ist seit
tagen in der ukraine das ist hier diese
in dem fall z markierung mit weißer
farbe das haben die russen auf alle ihre
kampfpanzer gemalt und ist für uns ein
stück weit eine chance diese panzer zu
verfolgen durch die ukraine
herauszufinden zu welchem verband sie
gehören und was womöglich auch ihr ziel
ist wenn wir jetzt in den panzer rhein
gucken dann sehen wir vorne im panzer
den fahrer er steuert den panzer oben
dann den rechtsschützen im turm und
neben ihm da ist der kommandant er
entscheidet abgeschossen wird oder nicht
wohin geschossen wird kommuniziert mit
den anderen panzern wenn man das jetzt
alles hört die erfahrung diese panzerung
dann klingt das jahr als würden die
russen in der ukraine mit ihrem blutigen
vormarsch vielleicht unproblematisch
vorankommen aber so ist es eben nicht
wenn wir gemeinsam mit hier auf unseren
monitor schauen dann sehen wir dort
aufnahmen aus der ukraine
und vor allem werden wir gleich sehen
70 explodiert weil er getroffen wurde
von einer anti panzer rakete die kurz
zuvor ukrainische soldaten abgefeuert
haben das ist das besondere an diesem
konflikt auf der einen seite der
jahrzehntealte panzer und auf der
anderen seite kann man sie mit mir mit
nach unten eine moderne hightech anti
panzer waffe nl a wieso wird sie
abgekürzt und genannt pure hightech ein
einzige abschluss mit dieser waffe der
kostet 40.000 dollar warum weil alles
automatisch passiert von computern
gesteuert wird der schütze der nimmt
sich diese rakete auf die schulter zielt
durch die sensorik dann hab da übernimmt
der computer steuert die rakete ins ziel
und eben in den t 72 panzern ich will
ihnen zeigen wie genau das aussieht und
was die folge von dem ist schauen wir
wieder auf unseren monitor und seen
unglaubliche aufnahmen ein ukrainischer
soldat der hat genau diese nrw
geschultert und er läuft er schlendert
durch eine rauchende und qualmende
landschaft hier rauchen und qualmen
t-72 kampfpanzer die sind zuvor von
genau diesen raketen ausgeschaltet
wurden von diesem ukrainischen soldaten
und seinen kameraden
aufnahmen die bleiben werden und die
eben auch zeigen dass jahr da kämpft auf
der einen seite eben dieser stahl koloss
goliath aber manchmal da gelingt es
david mit moderner technik geliefert
übrigens aus dem westen von nato-staaten
gegen goliath erfolgreich zuzuschlagen
und tödlich zu schlagen muss man ja
sagen denn natürlich ist es die panzer
besetzung ein mutiges und ein tragisches
ende